we're going to begin of course as we
often do this time with politics
election day now is just two weeks away
from today and Pennsylvania is a crucial
Battleground for both parties the latest
CBS News Battleground Tracker out this
morning finds a senate race between
Democrat John fetterman and Republican
Amendment Oz is a toss-up right now
fetterman leads Dr Oz by just about two
points that's according to our poll they
will have their only debate of the
campaign tonight in Harrisburg that of
course is a state capitol Robert Costa
is already there covering one of the
Senate races that will help decide who
controls Congress for the next two years
Bob it's good to see you this is a big
night for both candidates good morning
from Rainey Harrisburg the state capital
of Pennsylvania ahead of this high
stakes debate our new CBS News poll
shows the core voters in both parties
are now rallying around the Senate
nominees coming home as they say before
election day
when they take the stage a lot is on the
line for Republican mehmed Oz and
Democrat John Federman and for
Pennsylvania voters I'll keep us safe
cut your taxes and protect our jobs ozan
Republicans have linked veteran to
President Biden and made crime a focal
point all the law enforcement groups
have endorsed me because they know
fetterman doesn't have their back and
I'll fight hard to let them do their job
across the ballot the Republican push on
crime has led other Democrats to push
back including the state's attorney
general and Democratic gubernatorial
nominee voters are concerned about
Public Safety as they are the economy
and protecting their fundamental
freedoms and so I talk about this issue
wherever I go on the economy pain is
evident the new CBS News Battleground
tracker shows voters want to hear the
candidates views on the economy and
inflation policies what's it like when
you walk into a grocery store these days
as a college student and you look at the
prices
um how wrenching because I got a certain
amount of money for like the week and
then by the time I go grocery shopping
it's all gone who wants to pay
four dollars for gas
you know
that's that's really has to be the
number one issue and despite all that I
survived to be back
and that makes I'm gonna fight for you
all because I'm back out on the trial
better men who had a stroke in May has
been reassuring voters that he is ready
to serve his doctor has done the same
issuing a letter that the candidate has
no work restrictions and can work full
Duty in public office but uh as soon as
I have captioning I'm able to understand
exactly what's being asked veterans use
of a captioning device will be on
display during the debate in downtown
State College on a football weekend
voters weighed in I don't think anyone
should be shamed for using things that
make things more accessible for them I
think that people are wondering you know
can he handle the job there's just too
much attention on it says media Observer
Al Tompkins and more than half of the
voters agree saying they don't think
it's important to talk about fetterman's
health during the debate I think people
care about things like like inflation
and crime and international relations uh
trust in government are all important
issues for people
CBS News has learned that later this
week President Biden will return to
Pennsylvania to raise money for
Democrats in early next month in
November he will be back again that time
with former president Barack Obama they
will crisscross the state going from
Pittsburgh to Philadelphia highlighting
just how important this Battleground is
for the White House
you're right about that Bob thank you